ah
importante aprender a dar por las
personas que
desean emigrar el del país ya por la
situación económica
desean algo mejor para en su vida
entonces tenemos que enfrentar un gran
obstáculo que lo que el río bravo que
han habido muchos abogados
[Música]
estamos próximos a un viaje yo y mi hija
entonces por eso hemos decidido
tener un poquito de conocimiento por
aquellos que encontrás en el agua estás
en peligro anunciado un poquito de
conocimiento cómo podernos defender
han tenido que
desgraciadamente ver gente conocida y
que
conocida o conocidas de familiares que
han regresado o esté muertos me dan me
da tristeza miedo tanto son tanto los
los sentimientos encontrados que uno
siente pero igual vamos por un sueño
pues para darle un mejor futuro a la
familia